Markel reaction bracelet what do you
think I mean absolute uncertainty and
that's what the market hates and I think
it's we're in a very manipulative
situation right now because there's the
political aspects on both sides of the
ocean and how corporations deal with
those circumstances are going to
influence what happens going forward in
the UK and also here in our election and
what I'm talking about is if all of a
sudden we see JP Morgan and all these
different big financial companies say
you know what we're just moving
everybody to Berlin all of it now
there's a tangible impact on jobs and
that's going to influence a conversation
and it's the same in the United States
once you know we see that you know we're
talking about all this nationalism you
know you know Trump versus you know
senator Clinton or Secretary of State
Clinton now if all these businesses are
reacting to this take back our country
movement by leaving that sets the tone
for the election as well look if it
happened that all these companies said
we're out why would it be any different
here but on the flip side if the United
States is open and we adhere to our
treaties then all of a sudden tech
companies in particular in the UK who
want to be able to work with the
European Union and have the treaties
already in place they might come here
and if you see a big movement of tech
companies here because you know there's
no better tech you know Foundation and
employee base in and customer base than
United States protect we might see a
wholesale in flew low of those companies
which in one on one end says to the UK
prex it was a big mistake
and it also sends the message to our
economy and to us voters that
protectionism and cutting off those
treaties would be a huge mistake you
mention immigration I mean that's a
certainly a big part of it UK and it's a
big part of the nationalist discussion
is happening really led by Donald Trump
yeah I mean look immigration takes a lot
of different forms there's um high-end
you know for visas for employees that
you can't get there's you know people
being concerned about their lives
concerned about their jobs I am NOT a
fan of Donald Trump's approach you know
I'm a tech guy I mean
invested in companies that allow for or
create the ability to test and evaluate
people before they come a company called
come varus and that we're working we've
worked with Israel and Southern American
companies that say okay before you come
into this country we're going to put you
through this test and we're going to ask
you these series of questions and we can
tell with a high degree of accuracy
eighty five percent and there will learn
to be better on whether or not you're
going to have a negative impact whether
or not you're a terrorist whether or not
you're you know radical Islamic terror
you want to define people so there's
technology I think that our first steps
that everybody is ignoring and so I
would just take a completely different
approach are you concern about the tone
though the National September it's in
the in the UK or here absolutely it's
scary right I mean look in my mind hate
never hate never accomplishes anything
no one's ever won with hate and I think
that's the fundamental problem and hate
doesn't solve problems hate doesn't
improve the economy hate doesn't make
people harm doesn't protect our people
anymore doesn't protect the borders
anymore and so we've got to be very
careful about the verbage we use because
it's just that there's no win there I
don't know that you can condone take
it's no it was fair to connect the the
anti transgender bathroom rhetoric to
the crazy guy in Florida really - people
always gay people this gay club but I
thought it was interesting that you gave
a million bucks into Dallas police right
after that happened I just thought it
was the right thing to do I mean a lot
of times I've said that after a military
service the most patriotic thing you can
do is pay your taxes and the natural
response to that well if you want to pay
more feel free to write a check that's
what I've done multiple times not just
this time you know there's you know
several I don't four or five maybe six
now times I've written checks to the the
Treasury of the city of Dallas for a
variety of purposes earmark for
something specific and you know given
what was going on I wanted to set an
example and I wanted to send a message
that this shouldn't be tolerated and I'm
going to help pay our taxes it's a
natural segue it was a candidate refused
to release his tax forms what do you
think with it irrelevant absolutely
irrelevant I mean I know for my taxes
when it's tax time there's a big living
room table that I have and there's big
stacks all around the table and I just
look at the signature pages and it takes
45 minutes still design all that stuff
and so I couldn't talk actually I went
and looked but in any previous years to
this last one I could have told you how
much I've made or what was on my taxes
and it's certainly not a reflection of
net worth and I don't think it's a
reflection of how much anybody gives to
charity or anything and you know any one
given year may be up or down so I don't
care I don't care if they release their
taxes so why do you think he's not doing
it I have no idea my guess is that it
may have been a down year for him and
you know you know look if depending on
what your sources of income are you may
say I've made a fortune in the market
but I'm not going to take my profits and
he might have had a negative income and
that certainly wouldn't match up to his
brand so it doesn't matter and yet you
have some comments recently saying was
suggesting that he's actually gotten
Dumber as timers yeah and that's pretty
straightforward right so if you look at
how he's managed his campaign he went
from maybe I'll be the nominee to okay
I'm pretty much the presumptive nominee
even before the others fell out of the
race if he was smart he would have
started to learn that okay in a campaign
there's certain in a national campaign
there's certain things I'm going to have
to do there's certain skill sets I'm
going to need to make me smarter about
running a national campaign so did he go
out and hire people who can create a
ground game no did he go out and hire
people that could help him with an
advisory basis to help with the whole
political machine that's required to get
the vote out he tried and all those
people just keep on getting fired and
turning over and so rather than getting
smarter than bringing in the help that
he needed to run a campaign he's doing
the exact opposite and where we've
gotten to is him pretty much being
dependent on his kids and we're not it's
not like you know they're good kids
they're smart kids I've met them they're
their pressive in every which way but I
don't know that I'd want them all of a
sudden just coming in to run a campaign
this isn't Shark Tank right where it's
like okay you can help with this company
we're talking about running a campaign
for the president United States and you
know so getting stupider means not being
able to hire the skillsets that you need
to make you smart and so I think he's
gotten worse and we're seeing it happen
right before our very eyes
I'm dinner with some tech CEOs recently
people you know but I was off the record
Terry but I will tell you that what they
when we're going on the table talk about
politics
presidential choices for Hillary one of
these CEOs said you good seriously
good so yeah I mean look it's not going
to happen but you always got a you never
know until you take the first step and
you and you put it out there anything's
possible but I think tech illiteracy at
the top for both candidates is a huge
problem you know we talked about how do
you deal with immigration how do you
deal with radical Islamic terrorists
trying to come into the country from
wherever right it's not there's no way
just physically you can just interview
everybody you're going to need to use
tech whether it's conveyor sweather its
facial recognition there's a variety of
other options Tech is going to get us
there somebody's gotta at least start to
understand those things and how they
apply to all the big issues we're also
you know you talk about dealing with the
future autonomous cars robotics AI
machine learning jobs are going to
disappear you know this is there's going
to be jobs that are gone just like you
know making records in Terre Haute
Indiana were gone
making cameras from Kodak and in New
York were gone coal in Western Kentucky
they're gone those jobs are gone -
question is what are you going to do in
anticipation the fact that we may not
have replacements if you don't
anticipate if you don't understand the
issues you can't come up with solutions
and I think that's a relevant problem
that I can no one has the absolute
answer but at least I can help them
start to understand that and start to
come up with solutions I found almost
such gears a little bit to talk about
the insider trading the SEC I'd like to
talk about that subject I do too you
found an amicus brief of the Supreme
Court that it really hits the the
history of this on the head which is to
say that the definition of insider
trading has never been fine it doesn't
exist right but there's even a bigger
problem right the question is what's the
job of the SEC the job of the SEC is to
enable capital formation okay how would
they've done when you look at the end of
the year results from the SEC where they
talk about what they've done they never
do any research or show any evidence at
all to say that they've improved capital
formation and if you look at what's
happened over the last 20 years the
number of public listings has been cut
in half to under 4,000 and declining if
you look at the number if you look at
the number of IPOs
which is capital form
and to venture back high tech IPOs is
here and there's just a number in
general or following and in fact I saw
some data that said over the last five
years 15 percent of the money raised
through IPOs has gone to China and I
don't even know in terms of other
countries so it's not even the United
States that is benefiting the most from
IPOs and a lot of vertical markets right
so that's the second thing the second
question for the the sec is do people
have more confidence in the markets do
you know anybody who thinks the markets
safer today than it was 10 or 20 years
ago do you know anybody who thinks they
have that says they have more confidence
in the stock markets today than they did
20 years ago
and we're not even starting to introduce
the concept of high-frequency trading
and market structure issues yeah that's
a big part of it so that that's part two
I think that I think that the role the
SC's also make sure there's a fair and
level playing field and the markets and
takeaway advantages and take away
illegal if you don't know if you can't
do the first two you can't do the third
when you go to do the third - well
someone's got to be this so okay so
let's talk about the third right if you
really want to make a level playing
field you create bright-line rules you
make it so everybody understands so when
we talk about this tipping and Tippy's
there is nobody even in the SEC who can
give you a cogent description of what
the problem is when your legal stock tip
is what nobody knows right they take it
to the courts and they make they create
some of the most ridiculous suits ever
you know I mean there are some there's
my or the CEO of a biotech company calls
up Martha Stewart says hey my drugs not
approved great that's a pretty clear one
that's pretty clear but again if you the
question is and can you catch somebody
but if your lawyer you know that works
for the SEC the more people you catch
the better your job security is and the
better the job you're going to get when
you leave the SEC to go work in private
practice but that doesn't make the
country safer that doesn't make the
market safer if you want I'll give you a
perfect example right
I had a scenario I tend not to talk to
CEOs of public companies because I don't
trust the SEC they can come in and find
anything any time so I just don't trade
with them I don't talk to them but if um
if you try I called up I had a scenario
and I called up the SEC and I videotaped
this whole thing and put it on YouTube I
said I have a question before I trade or
do anything I want to know if
something's legal can you help me so
then they were nice they sent me to
somebody else who said okay what's the
question they said we can't answer
questions but they just want to hear the
question and they said what you have to
do is go to this page on the sec gov
website I went to that page on the sec
gov website you know what it was it was
a image of a fax of a page from 1980
this is on their website last year
saying send in 8 copies of your request
and maybe it will reply to it at some
point in time no assurances now if you
truly wanted to stop insider trading
if you truly wanted people to follow the
law you are a going to make it so
someone can ask ask a question and get
an answer because that's inherently
going to reduce the problem being you're
going to publish everything in an
easy-to-understand format so you don't
get a phil mickleson stuck in the middle
of something you don't I'll give you
another example of insider trading that
a suit they brought against somebody
there was a guy at a railroad company in
Illinois I think it was and he was a
middle level manager and he's driving to
work and every day for a couple of weeks
whatever the period was he's seeing
these limos in this city in Illinois you
don't see limos
there's limos in the parking lot he
thinks maybe we're getting acquired I'm
going to go buy some options so he does
they got acquired the SEC sued him for
insider trading he had no other
information no knowledge whatsoever and
intuition and they sued him for insider
trading
that's how ridiculous the SEC is the SEC
has no interest in stopping insider
trading they have no interest in
protecting us against people doing the
wrong thing look that the Justice
Department does more of that than the
SEC if it's criminal and it's really
truly insider trading it wrong the
Justice Department deals with it
from the SEC perspective they're this
they're about protecting their jobs if
they truly care about stopping insider
trading they would make it so easy to
just go on their website or make a phone
call and say these are the rules you
must follow these rules even though
there's not an official law they might
argue that into shifting target that if
as soon as you define the rules of
crooks to find a way around and so you
need to be a little bit those are the
people that you know are crooks the
problem isn't the crooks we're trying to
find their way around it the problem is
the innocent people get caught in this
trap and have that know you know no
indication what they what they were
doing is wrong
and in their minds it appears to be that
if you know there's some sort of
determined every time they bring a case
right boy I just brought this case
against Mark Cuban we're gonna you know
if we beat him you know no one else is
going to do it they're going to learn
maybe in 2008 when they messed with me
that was the case because media was
different now if you walk down the
street in New York City in the middle of
Wall Street and you listed ten names of
people who were found liable for insider
trading nobody would know who any of
them were now maybe some of the people
who are found criminally guilty from the
Justice Department but so there is no
difference yeah there is no deterrence
you know I get all the time I have
people coming to me that are being hit
by the SEC and they're saying what do
you do should I settle and this is
exactly what I tell them if you really
think you're innocent you can't afford
it settle because it's like a speeding
ticket yeah nobody knows so unless you
do it more than once what do you hope
happens this case before the Supreme
Court what's going to happen if you're
amicus briefs helps convince the court
of something I don't know I mean my the
whole thing in filing amicus brief is to
send them as if you notice there's an
underlying message that says the SE C's
responsibilities or a B and C that I
listed out and they're not doing any of
them and there's nothing to show that
they have any desire to accomplish any
of these goals and so that's always the
under pain that's why I keep on filing
these things and then on the the
administrative law of judges right
that's just wrong right we take taking
cases away from the courts and letting
the SEC an SEC appointed lawyer we we
have a right to a jury trial right we
have a right to be judged by our peers
not by an employee of the SEC and if you
think of all the things I just said
where the SE C's job and the SE C's goal
is not to protect the public not to
create confidence not to enhance um
capital formation right now the reality
is the SE C's goal is to create jobs for
lawyers at the SEC there's nothing that
they do you
can't name me one thing not one single
thing that the SEC has done in terms of
insider trading that is enhanced capital
formation made people more confident in
the market and made it easier for people
to understand the laws not one single
thing you can't I can't they can't and
they know it and they don't care and
that's a real problem if I was vice
president right I would be banging on
whoever the president was to get take
insider trading out of the SEC
completely some of the other things they
do okay take it completely out formalize
the law work with Congress to create the
law and just make it a Justice
Department issue save million billions
of dollars make the world a safer place